الحكومه اللبنانيه تلوح بقطع الكهرباء عن
مخيمات اللاجئين تاكيد جاء على لسان وزير
الطاقه والمياه وليد فياض الذي اكد ضروره
دفع تكلفه استهلاك اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
والسوريين من الكهرباء في البلاد وزير
الطاقه اللبنانيه المحافي تصريحاته
لامكانيه قطع الكهرباء عن المخيمات في حال
عدم السداد فياض برر ذلك الاجراء بعدم
استطاعه الدوله تامين الطاقه للمخيمات
والنازحين مجانا واستعجز في توفير الخدمه
تصريحات وزير الطاقه اثارت استياء بين
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين الذين تتفاقم
ازماتهم المعيشيه حيث بلغت نسبه الذين دون
خط الفقر فوق التسعين بالمئه بحسب ارقام
الانواع فيما اعقب اعلان فياض انتقادات
واسعه وجهتها منظمات حقوقيه وتنظيمات
فلسطينيه رات في قطع الكهرباء عن المخيمات
اجراء غير مسؤول لا يراعي ظروف لا شيء
كلنا لازم ندفع حق الكهرباء لانه هذه
الكهرباء اللي عم تتامن يوم عم تتامل الى
كلفه ويجب ان تغطى ان كان الانتاج او
التشغيل او التوزيع او الصيانه او
المعاشات كله هيدا لازم يتغطوا بيتغطى
وطبعا مش مطلوب من اللبنانيين انه يغطوا
كلفه استهلاك
الاخوان السوريين والفلسطينيين كل واحد
بده يخطي كلفه استهلاكه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات